and I am and will always be the girl
from the aisle
hey deaf Cameron we heard you had a
blast on the set of descendants three
and we can't really blame you we know
you spend a lot of time goofing off with
the cast but that never stopped you from
perfecting your dance moves
you gave us everything you had and more
in descendents three and we can't wait
to hear about the good times you shared
with bubu China and Sophia and Cameron
the cast of descendants three had the
time of their lives while on sets they
made new friends formed lifelong bonds
and created hundreds of memories along
the way but there's one story
dov and Sophia will never forget watch
until the end to find out what it is the
last scene during an interview with ABC
news booboo Stewart talked about the
many emotions he encountered while
filming the last scene of dissonance 3
according to the actor it wasn't even
the last day on set but filming the last
scene hit him right in the fields
and I'd literally could not save the
words Daffy Cameron and director Kenny
Ortega were sitting right next to boo
boo and they totally knew where he was
coming from the cosy credits the actors
of descendants three know how important
is to radiate energy on camera but they
also know that once the camera stops
rolling exhaustion settles in in this
behind-the-scenes moment we see the cast
laying down on the floor
they're super tired but still have it in
them to share a couple of laughs Cameron
Boyce is the only one still standing and
he's rearranging their hair for a final
scene when Kenny asks the gang what
scene they're filming Sofia tells him
they're filming the cozy credits if only
deaf Cameron let fans in on a top secret
story that occurred during the first
Descendants film she considers it to be
one of her most embarrassing moments
during an interview with 17 doves shared
a story about the time she got pranked
during her solo number if only dove was
convinced that there was no record of
the incidents but the clip eventually
surfaced in it we see Cameron Sophia
booboo and Mitchell running up behind
her dev heard them coming and thought
she was about to be attacked by a wild
animal she was so embarrassed when she
turned around
dance party if there's one thing that a
sentence cast has in common it's their
love for dance they're constantly
goofing around and singing along to some
of their favorite songs but when Kenny
yells cut that doesn't mean the dance
party is over because cast members like
Cameron voice china anne mcclain and
brennan d amico have a way of keeping
the party going we catch a glimpse of an
adorable cast moment in this short video
it's easy to see the bonds that these
friends share we are all capable of good
and bad no matter which side of the
barrier we come from the real meaning
behind the descendents franchise during
the very same interview with ABC news
director Kenny Ortega talked about the
true meaning behind the descendents
franchise Kenny spoke about how
empowering all through movies really
were he wanted to show viewers that
where you live or come from doesn't
matter in the end it's all about the
choices you make things that you don't
determine who someone is because of
where they live but you determine who
someone is because of the choices they
make in their life boo boo Dov and Kimmy
all believe that The Descendants movies
relate to the modern times in which we
live in can you see the similarities
tell us about them in the comments the
color of evil China Sophia and Cameron
loved to spend time together but that
never stopped them from engaging in some
friendly competition during an interview
with BuzzFeed the girls played a trivia
game about Disney Villains they had to
guess the color of the Evil Queen's eyes
and Sofia made her mother proud by
correctly naming the color green that's
when dove realize that Maleficent eyes
are green too so a midway through the
interview they concluded that green is
the color of evil symbolic relationship
it's time for a fun fact brought to you
by the lake grape Cameron voice and this
video Cameron uses his friends me as an
armrest after giving her a spot to sit
he goes on to explain that their
exchange is similar to a symbiotic
relationship Cameron talks about how
little fish follow sharks around the
Sharks give them protection and food
while the fish give the Sharks daily
cleanings Cameron totally had a
symbiotic relationship going on closer
than ever
The Descendants cast lost a member of
their family on July 6 2019 a blow that
many of them will never fully recover
from Kenny dove Sophia and boo boo told
stories about Cameron and how he made
everyone
according to the cast losing Cameron
brought them closer on an emotional
level and they continued to celebrate
him every step of the way
would you rather some interviews take on
a very serious tone and others are
downright ridiculous during an interview
with Niki and Sammy Sophia and boo boo
started laughing uncontrollably they had
to choose between saving their friends
from a wild goose or throwing seeds of
them mid attack these villain kids were
seriously amused by this question this
space between Evie and now are the best
of friends ever so it's only natural
that dub and Sophia are super close in
real life - if there's one memory dub
and Sophia will never forget it's
watching the final product of their duet
space between Sophia and of gush over
how much they love each other and almost
start to cry if that's not true
friendship we don't know what is which
one of these stories was your favorite
tell us in the comments real-life
stories from the cast of descendants
three give this video a big thumbs up if
you love everything Disney and - be sure
to subscribe to the things while you're
at it thanks for watching we'll catch
you later
[Music]